[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen es könnte einen neuen
fußball-bundestrainer geben Norbert
Julian nagelsmann
zwei Treffen ein Thema der Krieg in der
Ukraine beschäftigt die
unvollversammlung in New York in
Ramstein sagen die Verbündeten Kiew
langfristigem Militärhilfe zu
Kämpfe im Kaukasus Aserbaidschan startet
einen Angriff auf Armenia in der Region
Bergkarabach es gibt Berichte über Tote
und Verletzte
und Trainersuche beendet Julian
nagelsmann soll offenbar die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft übernehmen
vorerst bis zur heimwm 2024
zurzeit sind zahlreiche Staats- und
regierungschefinnen und Chefs der Welt
in New York bei der unfallversammlung
dabei geht es viel um den Krieg in der
Ukraine
erstmals seit dem russischen Angriff ist
der ukrainische Präsident selenski ins
Hauptquartier der Vereinten Nationen
gereist er soll in diesen Stunden vor
den unentsprechend über das Treffen der
Weltgemeinschaft in New York berichtet
Elmar Tierwesen
wenn sie sich wünschen könnten welches
Bild die Vereinten Nationen heute bieten
wäre es das von Einigkeit aber es
herrscht Krieg mitten in Europa der die
ganze Welt mit trifft die einen sehen
die Prinzipien der UN das Existenzrecht
eines
mitgliedsstaatsgefährdet andere wie der
Präsident Brasiliens werfen der NATO vor
den Krieg mit Waffenlieferungen zu
befeuern es folgt ein leidenschaftlicher
manchmal fast wütender Appell von Lula
da Silva die Welt dürfen nicht den
Einflusssphären geteilt und in einen
neuen Kalten Krieg gestürzt werden
keine Krieg offenbart unsere kollektive
Unfähigkeit die Ziele und Prinzipien der
un-karte durchzusetzen wir unterschätzen
nicht die Schwierigkeiten Frieden zu
erreichen aber keine Lösung wird
belastbar sein ohne Dialog
wurde
Joe Biden kommt zu spät um Lula
zuzuhören Russland sagt der Rechner
damit die Welt müde werde und Putin
weiter Krieg führen lasse
wenn wir die Kernprinzipien der
Vereinten Nationen aufgeben um einen
Aggressor zu beschwichtigen kann
irgendein Mitgliedstaat sicher sein dass
er geschützt ist wenn wir die Aufteilung
der Ukraine zulassen ist dann die
Unabhängigkeit irgendeiner Nation
gesichert
noch reden gerade erst hat er im
US-Fernsehen Putin mit Hitler verglichen
wiederholt er es hier wird das Emotionen
führen
gehen wir direkt zu wissen Emma bei der
unfallversammlung werden also gerade aus
dem globalen Süden Verhandlungen Ukraine
Krieg gefordert wie sieht es damit aus
also es gibt hier keine Verhandlungen
konkret am Rande der UN-Vollversammlung
aber es zeichnet sich an den
Redebeiträgen so ein bisschen ein Trend
ab jeder macht auf die un-karte
aufmerksam auf die territoriale
Integrität die für alle Staaten gelten
auch Präsident Erdogan aus der Türkei
hat das jetzt gerade in seiner Rede
getan hat noch einmal gesagt er will
Verhandlungen zwischen beiden Seiten
befeuern aber sagt unter dem Rubrum der
territorialen Integrität so geht es
eigentlich den meisten aber jeder
erwartet dann eben dass die eine oder
die andere Seite den ersten Schritt tut
wobei doch eigentlich viele jedenfalls
die Mehrheit nach wie vor der Meinung
sind das Russland der Aggressor ist den
ersten Schritt tun müsste der
Generalsekretär hat in seiner Rede
gesagt Kompromiss scheint so etwas wie
ein schmutziges Wort geworden zu sein
wir brauchen jetzt Staatskunst und keine
Spielchen damit meinte er vor allen
Dingen Russland aber es ist eben
nirgendwo in sich das Russland bereit
ist von seinen Maximalforderungen
abzurücken und deswegen werden wir auch
hier am Rande der un-woche keine
konkreten Verhandlungen erleben danke
nach New York MRT wissen
wie kann die Ukraine weiter militärisch
unterstützt werden darüber beraten etwa
50 verbündete Staaten die sogenannte
Ukraine Kontaktgruppe in Ramstein seit
Beginn des Krieges bis Ende Juli haben
die USA mit 42,1 Milliarden Euro die
meiste Militärhilfe zugesagt oder
bereits geleistet dahinter folgt
Deutschland mit
17,1 Milliarden
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
versprach ein weiteres Hilfspaket
florian neuhahn hat mehr
es ist das mittlerweile 15 Treffen des
ramstein-formats zu Waffenlieferungen
für ihn ist es das erste Russe im
ummerhof kommt als neuer
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine
nachdem sein Vorgänger über eine
Korruptionsaffäre stürzte er wird
freundlich begrüßt aber auch mit einer
kleinen Warnung
wir werden die Verwendung der
us-militärhilfen genau überprüfen
und wir werden gemeinsam mit unseren
ukrainischen Partnern sicherstellen dass
jede Unterstützung effektiv und sicher
genutzt wird
zum Beispiel diese US-amerikanischen
Abrams Kampfpanzer im Januar angekündigt
sollen sie die Ukraine in den nächsten
Tagen erreichen doch die großen
Hilfszusagen kommen derweil von anderen
Dänemark Tschechien und die Niederlande
kündigen heute an zunächst 15
sowjetische Kampfpanzer zu liefern
Deutschland verspricht ein neues
Hilfspaket über 400 Millionen Euro vor
allem für Munition Europa wird zum
größten Unterstützer der Ukraine das ist
das erste Mal dass wir das seit Ausbruch
des Krieges sehen und der Grund dafür
sind mehr Jahresprogramme also Zusagen
unterstützungszusagen für bis zu fünf
Jahre eine Entwicklung wie sich die USA
übrigens seit langem gewünscht haben
keine Bewegung dagegen in der beinahe
ewigen Debatte um taurus-mausflugkörper
Raketen mit hoher Reichweite die die
Ukraine von Deutschland wünscht da gäbe
es keinen neuen Stand heißt es heute
lapidar
unsere
Reisen im Gepäck die erneute Zusage des
Westens langfristig zu helfen aber nicht
den großen Durchbruch
in der Ukraine sind durch russische
Angriffe mindestens neun Menschen
getötet worden sechs von ihnen starben
in der Stadt kobians im Nordosten des
Landes durch eine Fliegerbombe in
Lemberg zerstörten Drohnen mehrere
Lagerhallen ein Arbeiter kam ums Leben
laut Caritas wurden 300 Tonnen
Hilfsgüter zerstört die dort lagerten
unter anderem warme Kleidung und
Generatoren für den Winter
werfen wir einen Blick auf die immer
größer werdende Gruppe von Menschen die
pflegebedürftig sind dass sie angemessen
und würde voll versorgt werden sollte
eigentlich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
sein aber viele Heime sind überfordert
es fehlt an Personal was das konkret für
Folgen hat beleuchtet nun eine
AOK-Studie zum Beispiel werden Menschen
häufig mit Medikamenten ruhiggestellt
Luise
beruhigungs- und Schlafmittel
verschrieben vom Arzt weil der Patient
nicht schlafen kann oder häufig unruhig
ist in diesem Pflegeheim im Landkreis
Ludwigsburg soll das nur die Notlösung
sein das wäre einfach alternativ
versuchen Möglichkeiten zu finden die
den Bewohner beruhigen oder
schlafrituale zu finden und die
Medikamente umgehen können doch häufig
komme es zu dauerverordnungen von
beruhigungs- und Schlafmitteln im
Schnitt bekämen siebeneinhalb Prozent
der Pflegeheimbewohner diese für länger
als die erlaubten vier Wochen zu diesem
Schluss kommt die Krankenkasse AOK in
ihrem aktuellen pflege-report die
Arzneimittel können süchtig machen sie
führen zu weiteren kognitiven
Verschlechterungen Angstgefühle ja die
Lebensqualität sinkt und das ist einfach
nicht notwendig die Krankenkasse
berichtet außerdem das Heimbewohner
häufig gar unnötig kurz vor ihrem Tod
ins Krankenhaus kämmen und Demenzkranke
oft behandelt werden müssten weil sie zu
wenig trinken das zu verhindern Aufgabe
eines oft unter besetzten Teams die
Stiftung Patientenschutz fordert mehr
Transparenz
wie ist die Versorgung mit Medikamenten
mit Fachärzten was ist mit
Psychopharmaka all das darf nicht
versickern sondern muss pro Einrichtung
offengelegt werden aus Sicht der AOK
müssten pflegende und Ärzte enger
zusammenarbeiten um die Lebensqualität
von Heimbewohnern zu verbessern
erstmals gibt es gegen einen deutschen
Kardinal den Verdacht sexualisierte
Gewalt ausgeübt zu haben es geht um den
bereits verstorbenen gründungsbischof
des urbustums und späteren Kardinal
Franz Hengsbach ihm werden drei sexuelle
Übergriffe in den 50er und 60er Jahren
vorgeworfen mindestens ein Opfer soll
minderjährig gewesen sein Kardinal
Hengsbach starten 1991 die katholische
Kirche untersucht die Vorwürfe
die neonazi-vereinigung Hammer Skins
Deutschland sowie die Teilorganisation
Crew 38 sind verboten worden und es gab
heute Razzien die Hammerskins gelten als
weltweites rechtsextremes Netzwerk seit
Anfang der 90er gibt es sie auch in
Deutschland mehr von Andreas Huppert
radikal rechtsextrem antisemitisch die
hämmerskind Deutschland ihr
Selbstverständnis wir sind die Elite der
rechtsextremen skinnets seit heute ist
die neonazi-vereinigung verboten Ration
am Morgen sowie hier in Berlin
Deutschland weit in insgesamt zehn
Bundesländer Vereinsheime Häuser
Wohnungen von mutmaßlichen
Führungspersonen werden durchsucht
Material beschlagnahmt ein Jahr lang
wurde die Aktion vorbereitet
der Rechtsextremismus bleibt die größte
extremistische Bedrohung für die
demokratische Grundordnung in
Deutschland und entsprechend handeln wir
weiter mit aller Entschiedenheit um
rechtsextremistische Strukturen zu
zerschlagen die gekreuzten Hämmer als
Symbol die Neonazi-Gruppe hat ihre
Wurzeln in den USA international
vernetzt ist Hermanns Kind hierzulande
vor allem durch Rechtsrock Konzerte und
kampfsportveranstaltungen in der
Erscheinung getreten damit hat die
Gruppe Geld verdient genau wie mit dem
Verkauf rechtsextremistischer
devotionale gerade bei rechts vor
Konzerten wenn dann verschiedene Akteure
zusammenkommen man sie auch noch
austauschen kann man beispielsweise
merchandise heißt T-Shirts Hoodies
andere Kleidungsstücke kaufen kann
entwickelt sich ein starkes
Identitätsgefühl und das ist natürlich
das die Einstiegstür in den Extremismus
bundesweit werden die Behörden des
Verbot von Hammer Skins alt wichtigen
Erfolg im Kampf gegen Rechtsextremismus
in Deutschland
jetzt zu einem Konflikt der seit langem
Schwert nun aber eine neue
Eskalationsstufe erreicht hat es geht um
die Region Bergkarabach
aserbaidschan hat dort einen
Militäreinsatz gestartet spricht
offiziell von einer Anti
terror-operation
die Region im Südosten des Kaukasus
gehört völkerrechtlich zu Aserbaidschan
in dem Gebiet leben aber überwiegend
armenierinnen und Armenia schon zwei
Kriege haben die beiden Ex sowit
Republiken um Bergkarabach geführt
zuletzt vor drei Jahren mit mehr als
6.500 Toten Nina Niebergall
Aufnahmen aus der panacart der
Hauptstadt bergkarabachs ein Wohngebäude
offenbar beschossen in Bergkarabach
klingt es nach Krieg Behörden vor Ort
berichten von Raketen und
Artilleriebeschuss es werden Verletzte
und Tote gemeldet
das aserbaidschanische
Verteidigungsministerium veröffentlicht
diese drohnenaufnahmen
es ist eine Fortsetzung der Politik des
maximalen Drucks gegenüber den in
Bergkarabach lebenden armenierinnen und
Armenien jetzt eben unter Einsatz
militärischer Mitteln die Lage in
Bergkarabach gilt seit Monaten als
katastrophal Schlange stehen hoffen auf
Brot für die gut 120.000 Menschen dort
Realität die Regale sind leer es fehlen
Lebensmittel Medikamente Benzin häufig
fahren nicht mal mehr Krankenwagen denn
Aserbaidschan blockiert die einzige
Verbindungsstraße zwischen Armenien und
Bergkarabach Hilfslieferungen kommen
kaum noch durch
jetzt ist eben man an diesem Punkt
rausgekommen an dem neuen Monate
aushungern dann auch dann auch erheblich
an Kräften gezehrt haben so dass einfach
auch die Menschen geschwächt sind sie
sind geschwächtnisse die sind geschwächt
psychisch und dazu jetzt eben noch der
Militärschlag oben drauf
Armeniens Regierungschef Pasching
anspricht von ethnischen Säuberungen er
bittet den UN-Sicherheitsrat und auch
Russland um Hilfe
Hausarbeit Jan erklärte man werde den
Militäreinsatz erst beenden wenn die
Führungen der Karabach zurücktritt
es könnte also ein neuer Krieg zwischen
Armenien und Aserbaidschan drohen Armin
Körper warum eskaliert der Konflikt
gerade jetzt militärisch
hinter den Konfliktparteien stehen zwei
militärische Schwergewichte und das
macht die Sache so brenzlig also bei Jan
wird seit jeher von der Türkei
unterstützt Russland ist seit 1995
vertraglich die Schutzmacht von Armenien
wenn man sich jetzt die Ereignisse der
letzten Wochen und Monate mal anschaut
dann sieht man dass es eigentlich auf
eine Eskalation hinliegt als
Aserbaidschan Berg Karabach abgeriegelt
hat da haben die russischen
Friedenstruppen die seit drei Jahren
dort stationiert sind tatenlos
zugeschaut daran sieht man das für
Russland in der aktuellen Situation
Aserbaidschan und vor allem die Türkei
geopolitisch viel interessanter sind als
das kleine Armenien dort hat man prompt
reagiert hat hilft Lieferungen in die
Ukraine geschickt und Militärübungen mit
den USA veranstaltet was man hier hinter
mir im Kreml natürlich nicht besonders
gut fand last but not least haben sich
vor etwa drei Wochen die Präsidenten
Erdogan und Putin im russischen
getroffen und über bergerbach verhandelt
es ist also kein Zufall dass das alles
jetzt passiert und man muss ganz klar
feststellen dass dieser ganze Konflikt
zeigt wie sich die Kräfte Verhältnisse
in Osteuropa in der Zeit des Ukraine
Kriegs verschieben könnten danke für
diese Einschätzung
und zum aktuellen Geschehen im
bergharbach gibt es gleich auch eine
heute Live-Sendung zu sehen ab 19.30 auf
unserer App und in den Social Media
Kanälen
in Libyen ist nach der Flutkatastrophe
die Versorgungslage weiter alarmierend
tausende Menschen haben kein Zugang zu
sauberen Trinkwasser fachleute warnen
vor dem Ausbruch von Krankheiten vor
allem in der zerstörten Hafenstadt Dana
werden immer noch Leichen gefunden
10.000 sind obdachlos inzwischen schlägt
die Verzweiflung der Menschen dort in
Wut um vicolini attai berichtet
ihr Schock hat sich in Wut verwandelt
für die Demonstranten in Dörner ist klar
die Katastrophe ist vor allem
menschengemacht die Verantwortung tragen
so sagen sie die korrupten Politiker aus
Libyens
den Parlament geht es nur darum das Geld
der Stadt zu stehlen wir fordern dass
unsere Familien mitentscheiden über die
Maßnahmen hier
wir wollen das niemals liebische Firmen
beauftragt werden beim Wiederaufbau denn
all unsere Politiker vom Gemeinderat bis
zu den Behörden sind korrupt
alle Hilfe für Dörner solle
international beaufsichtigt werden
fordern sie damit Spenden nicht in
falsche Taschen verschwinden
ein Ingenieur der Stadt blickt mit Sorge
in die Zukunft er erwartet eine zweite
Katastrophe das Abwassersystem der Stadt
ist kollabiert die Folgen könnten
Krankheiten sein wie Typhus Hepatitis
oder Cola
wir brauchen ein schnelles Eingreifen
hier es werden dringend neue Rohre und
Anlagen benötigt
vergangene Nacht zündeten die
Demonstranten das Haus des
Bürgermeisters von Werner an die
Machthaber reagierten prompt das Militär
schüchtert Einwohner ein es behindert
freiwillige Helfer an ihrer Arbeit und
verweigert selbst einem Team der UN den
Zugang
die Menschen in Libyen brauchen Hilfe
wenn sie spenden wollen können Sie das
über das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die iban.de
65/100-400
600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe
Libyen infos auch unter
spenden.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
Überschwemmung nach Sturm und Regen wie
in Libyen aber auch Hitze und Dürre die
Wetterextreme häufen sich auch in
Deutschland höchste Zeit sich besser zu
schützen sagen Fachleute wie man sich an
nicht mehr vermeidbare Klimaveränderung
anpassen kann dazu gibt es seit langem
eine Strategie vom Bund doch konkret
passiert ist wenig das soll sich nun
ändern Andreas Stamm
eine Stadt passt sich an an die Folgen
des Klimawandels bis 2025 will Rotterdam
Klima sicher sein erklärt Johann
wallinde Manager des anpassungsprogramms
heißt vor allem sicher vor häufigeren
und heftigeren Regenfällen deshalb
wurden zentrale Plätze zu auffangbasis
umgestaltet
sobald es regnet sammelt sich das Wasser
aus der Umgebung und von den Hausdächern
hier in diesen Becken sie sind dann bis
hierher gefüllt nach 24 Stunden wird das
Wasser kontrolliert abgelassen und
Überflutungen verhindert was Leben
retten kann so wer Linde Schutz vor
Wassermassen bieten auch Dachgärten die
Regen wie ein Schwamm aufsaugen und dann
heißen Tagen die Feuchtigkeit wieder
abgeben so die Umgebung kühlen gegen
Extremwetter Folgen kämpft auch die
erste anpassungsmanagerin der Stadt Hamm
ihre Idee gegen Rekordhitze Nebel
Duschen leider fehlt ein Bauteil alle
Anfang ist schwer bei der Anpassung
eigentlich sollte das ja ein Thema sein
was alle beschäftigt und wo
man kalt ja auch merkt dass Maßnahmen
schnell und effizient umgesetzt werden
aber andererseits ein riesiges
Bürokratiemonster dahinter steht ein
2008 formulierte Strategie Papier der
damaligen Bundesregierung soll nun 15
Jahre später gesetzt werden die
Klimaanpassung beschleunigen viel
verschenkte Zeit zu Kritiker in der in
Rotterdam Tegel wippen groß wurde ein
Wettkampf zwischen niederländischen
Städten Ziel möglichst viele
Pflastersteine entfernen Flächen
entsiegeln Städte begrünen die
spielerisch Klima sich ja machen
so und jetzt kommen wir zur
sportnachricht des Tages Norbert Julian
nagelsmann könnte also neuer
Bundestrainer werden sieht wirklich ganz
danach aus der DFB der hat uns vorhin
wörtlich bestätigt wir sind in guten
Gesprächen nagelsmann soll offenbar den
Job zunächst nur bis einschließlich der
Fußball Heim EM in den nächsten Sommer
übernehmen
erfahren belastbar sofort zu haben so
jemanden hat der DFB gesucht und mit
Julian nagelsmann offenbar gefunden der
36-Jährige wäre wie schon beim FC Bayern
Nachfolger von Hansi Flick zwei Wochen
nach dessen aus beim DFB seit einem
halben Jahr ist nagelsmann bei den
Bayern freigestellt als Zwölfter und
zweitjüngster Bundestrainer der DFB
Geschichte dürfte er sich dort auf
deutlich geringere Bezüge einstellen für
seine Nachfolger in München ist
nagelsmann mit dem DFB schon einig
Juliana seine Qualität und der der sich
dafür entschieden und er hat sich dafür
entschieden und damit es die wichtigste
Voraussetzung gegeben es gibt eine
Entscheidung und das ist ähm kann nach
vorne blicken und dann ab sofort positiv
in die Sachen beeinflussen und dann wird
alles gut die Personalie Bedarf beim DFB
noch der Abstimmung in Aufsichtsrat und
Präsidium die nächsten Sitzungstermine
sind diese Woche Freitag
zur Fußball Champions League das Spiel
Leipzig zu Stunde in Bern gegen die
Young Boys ein weitaus schwereres
Auswärtsspiel dagegen später für
Dortmund der BVB trifft auf den
französischen Meister Paris
gleich zum königsklassenauftakt in Paris
Dortmund nach dem 4:2 zuletzt in
Freiburg mit Selbstbewusstsein aber auch
mit Respekt vor allem vor ihm dem wohl
besten Stürmer der Welt Kilian mbappé er
persönlich hat sich im brutales Tempo
ist sehr schnell auch mit Ball hat
schnelle Bewegung kann schnell
abschießen hat einen guten Abschluss den
schnellen psg-angriff komplettieren
Dembélé und kolomyani der BVB-Coach
möchte sein Team aber nicht nur
verteidigen sehen es gibt halt nur
diesen einen Ball auf dem Platz und
sorgt dafür dass es deiner wird und ähm
lass uns alles dafür investieren in den
Ball besitzt so ungefährlich wie möglich
zu machen vorne könnte es auf Niklas
Füllkrug ankommen dem Neuzugang winkt
das Start 11 Debüt für den formschwachen
alle Spiele alle Tore auch die von
Mittwoch bei uns zu sehen morgen abend
Sportstudio Champions League 23 Uhr tip
top danke
um sie am Nachthimmel tanzen zu sehen
reisen viele in den hohen Norden oder
ganz weit in den Süden Polarlichter
diesmal reichte eine Fahrt nach
Magdeburg denn dort zeigte sich in der
Nacht das Naturschauspiel ein
schillerndes buntes Leuchten eben wie
auf Spitzbergen oder in der Antarktis
Magdeburg wird aber wohl nicht zum neuen
Pilgerort für Fans des mystischen
Spektakels tausende Kilometer von Nord-
und Südpol entfernt bleiben Polarlichter
eine Seltenheit
morgen scheint besonders im Süden viel
die Sonne mehr Details gleich von
Christa Orben das heute Journal hat um
21:45
[Musik]
guten Abend der September macht ja im
Moment was die Temperaturen betrifft
einem Sommermonat alle Ehre und jetzt
wird es auch noch mal eine Spur mildert
denn dieses Tiefpunkt jetzt weiter
spätsommerliche Luft zu uns außerdem hat
es dafür gesorgt dass es heute richtig
windig teils stürmisch war es bleibt
heute Nacht an den Küsten auch stürmisch
sonst lässt der Wind etwas nach im
Norden und Nordwesten bleibt es aber bei
dichten wolkengebietweise etwas Regen
Richtung Süden ist es häufiger klar und
ganz im Süden bildet sich stellenweise
Nebel hier sinken die Temperaturen dann
auch um 7 Grad unter den dichten Wolken
bleibt es deutlich milder 17 Grad an der
Nordsee und auf der Nordsee da gibt es
auch morgen noch stürmische Böden
generell ein frischer Südwestwind im
Nordwesten des Landes hier auch mehr
Wolken noch einzelne Schauer und
nachmittags wird dann hier freundlicher
sehr freundlich startet der Tag aber
schon im Südosten hier auch weniger Wind
im Vergleich zu heute nachdem sich der
Nebel auch aufgelöst hat dazu dieses
spätsommerliche Temperaturniveau 21 Grad
in Schleswig-Holstein 25 Grad und mehr
im Osten und im Südwesten des Landes ja
und der Donnerstag leg noch mal eine
Schippe drauf bis 29 Grad vor allem in
Brandenburg in Sachsen-Anhalt dann wird
von West nach Ost mit Gewittern und
schauen aber Kühler tschüss